we can speak now to kurt volker who's a
former us ambassador to nato he's also
served
as the u.s special representative for
negotiations
on ukraine now mr volcker a very good
evening to you
thank you for taking the time to speak
to us if we could start
by talking about afghanistan of course
just listening to president
biden there um inheriting the pledge
from president trump for full withdrawal
of troops he's
now committed to that taking place by
september the 11th
um pretty clear though from what he's
saying the underlying message is
afghanistan is no longer
a key foreign policy priority
uh well i think he's facing the same
domestic
pressures to pull u.s troops out that
president trump faced and
even president obama faced before him if
you remember president obama in 2009
already articulated the first effort to
have a withdrawal deadline
the problem with withdrawal deadlines
whether it's the may first deadline that
president trump had tried to set or this
new september one
is you're really putting the cards in
the hands of the taliban to wait it out
and then take over the country
and we do risk a return to taliban rule
the brutality of that rule possible uh
partnership with terrorists or other
extremists as well
so this is going to be a challenge for
some time to come
i think it's great that tony blinken was
in nato today i'm sure had a chance to
talk about this with our allies
i'm sure they would have liked to have
had more notice to think about what it
means for their own deployments
in afghanistan with the u.s pulling out
all the way
i expect there'll be a lot of discussion
now at nato after this
on how everybody gets out yeah i mean we
were hearing from
the president that you he couldn't just
keep waiting for the conditions to be
right
to get u.s troops home if that's the
case
should u.s troops have been home years
ago
well it does beg that question and it
also makes you wonder what was the point
of all that life and
treasure that was expended in
afghanistan we went into afghanistan
in 2001 2002 after the attack september
11
to prevent the territory from being used
by terrorists again
and then after doing so trying to leave
something sustainable behind
that sustainability has been elusive we
have not been able to have
an afghan government strong enough and
competent enough on security to survive
without international support and the
risk now is that
with the u.s pulling out it will again
be a toppling of that government a
toppling of the constitution
and a restoration of taliban rule let's
move on if we can to talk about the
situation
with russia and and ukraine as a former
u.s special representative
for ukraine negotiations in your view
what is mr putin up to
i think he's trying to demonstrate that
he is still the undisputed
uh dominant player in the region he's
the one with the
capability and the willingness to use
force whereas the west will not be
willing to do so
and in doing so he's trying to both show
to the russian people
that he is going to defend russian
interests against perceived threats from
outside made up threats frankly
but that's how he portrays them through
disinformation he's trying to show to
the ukrainians that
as much as they want to be a part of
europe that they can't really count on
europe for the united states to come to
their aid
and he's also trying to poke a little
bit of a hole in the biden
administration
after the use of the word killer by
george stephanopoulos and
in interviewing president biden about
putin i think he's trying to show
that the u.s words and u.s policies are
hollow
whereas putin himself is the one who's
willing to actually use force
well i suppose if what president putin
wanted was come hither
to uh president biden then it looks
quite successful doesn't it because
president biden picked up
the phone to him yesterday and he has
suggested a meeting in a third country
it's rather remarkable when you consider
the number of things that russia has
done
to harm us and western interests
whether it is in ukraine whether it's
cyber attacks
whether it's election meddling whether
it's killing people or attempting to
kill people
on our soil uh poisoning of navalny
airspace violations flying over warships
and on and on
that the outreach would be made to say
okay let's have a meeting
i suppose one of the upsides of making
such an offer to have a summit
is it may cause putin to ratchet down
a little bit on ukraine or on some other
issues in advance of such a meeting
but on the other hand it's clear that
putin will have expectations from the
u.s
and from the west of what he wants i
hope that the u.s and the west are very
clear about
changes in russian behavior that will be
needed for any kind of normalization of
a relationship
mr volcker you you referred to uh
perceived hollow posturing from
from western powers perhaps that's how
president putin sees it
um do you think he could be forgiven for
thinking that no western power would go
to war
over ukraine uh
no i i think that he is accurate in
thinking that i'm not
i don't believe that the united states
or europe britain would go to war with
russia
uh in general and uh in particular over
ukraine
that being said i think we should be
willing to take some very strong
measures now
even to ward off to deter such an
invasion
a couple of things we could do is
accelerate security assistance to
ukraine so that they are better capable
of defending themselves
we could be talking about the additional
sanctions we would put in place
if russia were to launch a new offensive
we could take several additional
diplomatic steps including some senior
visitors going to ukraine
naming a u.s ambassador naming a special
representative for
engaging in the international diplomacy
uh there's a lot more that we could be
ramping up right now to
uh convince putin that we are serious
about ukraine even if
we are not willing to go to war over
ukraine two of the things that seem to
be most effective
in uh instead of hitting president putin
when it where it hurts is either
a show of sheer force and you're saying
that you don't think any of the powers
are going to go to war over ukraine or
albeit there's u.s warships and
going to the black sea at the moment the
other thing is is economic sanctions of
course which which we've had it's hurt
putin in the past
um we're starting to see coordinated use
of the magnitsky act
what could be the next stage could it be
going for higher level targets people
who are closer
to putin could it be for example
boycotting russian sovereign debt in the
markets
yes the idea of boycotting russian
sovereign debt is one i've heard and i
think is
being actively looked at uh i think it
could have an impact
also going after people who are very
close to putin for personal sanctions uh
both on wealth that on travel
uh i think that would be something uh
we've seen the uk already take some
steps
concerning uh the harboring of money in
the uk and going after some oligarchs
i think that could be strengthened as
well so there are a number of steps on
the economic sanction side
i think that europe should be looking
very carefully at suspending the
nordstrom 2 project
this is something that is very
beneficial to russia and creates a
constituency in germany
to maintain a close relationship with
russia if that were to be put on hold
i think that would also be a positive
step on the military side
i want to come back and say that ukraine
has spent the last five to six years
strengthening its military capabilities
the us and others including the uk have
contributed to that
we've provided anti-tank weapons and
provided anti-sniper systems
we've given them better intelligence
capabilities uh there are more things
however that we could still do
to help ukraine defend itself and to
make any russian
uh new uh offensive uh much more
difficult for russia
these would include helping them in the
areas of air defense
in electronic warfare counter-electronic
warfare
maritime domain awareness and some help
even with the development of ukraine's
the redevelopment of ukraine's navy
mr volcker we don't often get the
opportunity to talk to you so just want
to step back
a little bit uh president obama's first
defense secretary
robert gates said of joe biden he has
been
wrong on nearly every major foreign
policy and national security issue
over the past four decades i'm wondering
do you agree with that
and if so has he learnt from his
mistakes
well i think that's a bit harsh uh i i
understand why
secretary gates said that but i think
it's a bit harsh and i think
uh joe biden has been around in politics
and foreign policy and national security
policy for close to 40 years
so he's bound to have been wrong on some
issues he's bound to have been right on
some other issues
uh on some of these though i think there
is a danger of
mistaking the strong words and the
strong rhetoric
from the determination to take action
and just to give you an illustration of
the way putin would look at something
he sees this tough talk from the united
states about himself or about china
but then he also sees the announcement
on the defense budget where
in real terms it's going to be a
decrease and that's going to result in
cancellation of some programs
and so i think putin will read that as
well you're talking a big game but on
the action side it's coming up short
i hope that what we were able to do in
the months ahead is to
start laying down actions that will
be leave an impression on putin on xi
on iran and so forth uh actions such as
sanctions or
increased military and security
assistance forward deployments such as
we have these destroyers in the black
sea
uh things like that that would actually
cause putin to change his calculus we
haven't seen enough of that yet but we
have
early days in the administration and
some months that had to go
all right fascinating to talk to you
kurt volcker thank you very much
for your time